foreign
[Music]
IST at GSK in our statistics and data
science Innovation Hub
where my team is working on building
support systems and facilitating the
adoption of our across biostatistics
today I'll be talking about our package
assessment lessons that can be learned
from Pharma
in today's world we have no shortage of
products right at our fingertips that
can be received in just days or even
hours with a click of a mouse vendors of
all shapes and sizes have the ability to
reach consumers across the globe
which means as consumers we have a wide
variety of features to choose from
but also quite a range of quality
sound familiar
whether you're looking for something you
need on Amazon or a package on crayon
you probably want to find something that
suits your needs that you can count on
so
what how do you make those decisions
what do you look for uh
turn you're probably going to look at
indicators that you feel are important
so if you think about how you you
approach online shopping you probably go
to the reviews the ratings badges the
name of the seller and depending on what
you're looking for how much time you
have maybe you deep dive into those
reviews
while the indicators and I'll say that
the indicators give you an overall
picture of confidence of whether the
product is going to look feel and
perform as advertised
while the indicators are a little bit
different for packages the overall idea
is the same
a little bit of research is going to go
a long way to build that picture of
confidence that the package is going to
to produce results that that you can
count on that are accurate now this this
idea is is absolutely critical to those
of us
in I mean it doesn't matter your work
but it's especially critical to those of
us in regulated Industries like Pharma
where it's really important for us to
deliver safe and effective drugs to
patients as as quickly as as we can
and to do so we we need to make sure our
data and our analysis our entire
pipelines are free of errors and full of
integrity
a huge part of our soft of our pipelines
is the software that's used to produce
the results transform the data all that
type of stuff we we really want to do
our research and The Regulators expect
that that we do our due diligence and
make defensible choices
so Regulators expect that our choices
are defensible meaning that we we want
to do our due diligence and provide
sufficient documentation of why we feel
that our our software our packages
work correctly and produce correct
results
so let's think about that for a minute
how do we really know our results are
correct
um
well
one thing we can do is compare against
the source of truth that source of Truth
could be your common sense another
programmer another programming language
maybe a publication like a textbook even
um and this is true regardless of
whether using the latest and greatest r
package or a SAS proc that's been around
for decades
it's all the same idea and we want to
make sure that our results are going to
be accurate for many scenarios we
haven't encountered yet many new data
sets new studies in the future
we're in exciting times now and Pharma
is making progress Full Speed Ahead
towards our being a primary tool used in
in studies and submission work
folks across the industry are putting
their heads together to to
align on a common Philosophy for what it
takes to ensure that our packages are
accurate in the our validation Hub
specifically this philosophy focuses on
a package assessment
and there's some principles and some
ideas in place but it's up to the
individual organizations to then
implement it for themselves and really
decide how much evidence is enough
at GSK uh we're we're working hard on
our own implementation and we've settled
on a set of guiding principles for uh
how we think about package assessment
and I'll present those to you today as
the domains of trustworthiness
there's five of them each one plays an
important role in the overall assessment
and each one consists of a collection of
things
those things are sometimes quite easy to
measure quantifiable but others are a
little bit more nuanced harder to
measure more subjective
so let's step through these now
beginning with the community domain
the the purpose of this domain is to get
an idea of how broadly used a package is
in the community how how much folks are
enjoying it how strong its roots are
so specifically we can look at something
like downloads to get an idea of the
volume of use to date and that volume of
use is an indicator of how much the
package has been vetted in real life
scenarios how much it's been stress
tested
we are also interested in the the
overall trajectory of that use is it
gaining traction is the package
maintaining or declining for some reason
maybe there's another package that's
come along that's uh that's superseded
it um
we also want to look at how the
community relates to the package and its
maintainers both
how the community relies on this package
depends on this package as part of other
software or other materials like books
and also going the opposite direction
how much the package maintainer
has a vested interest in supporting them
the community and keeping up with the
ever evolving many moving parts of the
the community
now something to keep in mind is in an
industry like Pharma we have some fairly
specific needs maybe our packages that
we are choosing are a little more Niche
or we have some internal packages that
we're using so by Nature these are going
to have a little bit smaller Community
user base and and that's okay we have
other domains to look at as well
with the authorship domain we are doing
some research to to learn who the
developers are what are their
backgrounds their experience
um and really does that experience is
that appropriate match for the
complexity of the tool
we found this one to be fairly important
for statistical packages where that
level of expertise is quite High quite
specific
so so some things that we look at here
are the overall reputation how the the
community regards this author as an
expert in their field
um as an art developer and how much
experience they have in both those areas
um so something you can look at is the
other packages that that person or those
individuals might have out there
and any specific
qualifications degrees certificates
things like that all round out to our
picture of who these authors are and
what their backgrounds are
and this this domain is quite dependent
on what you can find out there which
obviously varies from Individual to
individual so
um it's it's important nonetheless
our next domain is the documentation
domain uh which here I I intend to cover
functionality documentation so what is
the tool supposed to do what is the
intent and what what is the scope what
are the limits of that tool to help us
understand what is appropriate use what
is responsible use this is kind of a
prerequisite to to being able to prove
accuracy you need to understand in which
cases your function is going to produce
correct results
so documentation we are all probably
pretty familiar with looking around at
help files vignettes examples
so
what we're after is you know do those
things exist but also what is their
quality how helpful and clear are they
what types of scenarios are covered and
then for the intended use
clear documentation of expected inputs
expected outputs
really nice if uh education the limits
piece is covered in there what what what
might be one to watch out for when we're
using this tool
for instance
and this leads us into the software
development life cycle domain which we
are aiming to capture the overall
process for how the code develops and
evolves over time
how it is cared for essentially
with this one first and foremost we need
transparency into what's happening and
luckily for us this is
increasingly easy uh with with things
like GitHub where which is pretty
popular these days allows us to get a
peek into what's going on what kind of
branching model is being used how are
things being worked on and merged in and
are there any what is the road map of
the tool are there any critical open
issues
um all things we can look at just by
peeking into that Repository
and to get a sense of how well supported
it is we can also look at the activity
um
how quickly the the code or how often
the code is being worked on issues being
closed releases to crayon
and then any safeguards that are in
place to protect the Integrity of the
code as it evolves protective branches
continuous checking continuous testing
all to prevent against the any bugs
being introduced as this changes
now something to keep in mind is is a
package could have all the Hallmarks of
a good package here
but maybe it's really really new and it
hasn't had a chance to work out some of
some of the bugs and uh you know we're
not aware of those yet and it hasn't
been stress tested enough yet uh or it's
it's changing a lot on the other end of
things a package could have fairly
stalled development which could mean
it's been abandoned or it could mean
it's just really really stable so
something to keep in mind and looking at
this domain is what is the history of
the project where is it in terms of its
life cycle
and our final domain is the testing
domain
so here testing I mean the actual
testing inside the package oftentimes
this is your test stat your unit tests
and what these do is check that the
functionality is working as expected and
that it's producing correct results
which
sounds a lot like our definition of
accuracy that we talked about earlier so
a really solid test Suite can be
essentially a gold standard for for how
you can prove accuracy
so let's take a look at what we might
look for inside the package
so this is your your package directory
but we can look at whether test exists
and what they're covering so things like
code coverage which which functions are
being covered and to what extent and
that from there we can look specifically
at what we're interested in what are the
key things that we feel we are going to
be using the most
and how deep that testing is on those so
what types of scenarios are covered
there what types of inputs are are
developed the developers looking for and
are they comparing against some known
value even better if that source of
truth comes from some outside resource
now I recognize this is a fairly
technical task so this may look a little
bit different depending on on who you
are and what resources you have but even
being familiar with the first two the
presence the depth or sorry the presence
the breath and then um taking a peek
into the depth maybe like the some of
those descriptions and the test that can
be very helpful
another thing to think to keep in mind
about the testing domain is not
everything is super easy to test
sometimes visualizations or complex
algorithms can be a little bit really
novel complex algorithms can be a little
bit tougher to test so um that's okay
it's just you know that again we have
the rest of the the domains
so with those in mind
um
the assessment may look a little bit
different depending on who you are and
what you do
um for us we are very much working
towards our for submission work are
we're very risk-averse in this situation
we do a
a pretty in-depth assessment
um
so you know if you're just kind of
poking around exploring you you maybe
you do a little bit lighter of
assessment but getting to know your your
packages is really important and it will
serve you well
also on a task level uh if you're
transforming the data changing the data
in some way or performing a statistical
analysis the stakes might be a little
bit higher if
if something goes awry
as compared to and also it might be
harder to tell when something goes awry
as compared to something that's more
aesthetic in nature
um so again your approach to the
assessment might change depending on
that
um and so you could also perform this
whole assessment and not be quite
satisfied with with the results but
maybe you have only one option and this
is the package you need so you maybe
you're willing to bend a little bit on
your your risk and and build some extra
safeguards around that for yourself
augment it with some testing or extra QC
so even if you find yourself in the left
side very much in the stable risk-averse
the rest of the ecosystem is going to
continue to evolve and change and that's
the beauty of our right there's Cutting
Edge newer things every single day
so it's important for us
you know if we are in that situation to
keep our eyes up ahead of what's to come
and find ways to innovate find ways to
experiment and and keep our minds open
for any gems that come along and we can
in turn then grow our tried and true
collection of of packages that we count
on
all right so I said there were five
domains but I'm going to throw you one
more which is the domain about thinking
holistically
so when we do these assessments we are
not expecting a perfect score by any
means
um
the packages the purpose of the
assessment is to allow these packages to
shine where they are strong and let
those strengths their weaknesses guide
us in the rest of our assessment and
help us focus in on on what matters
um
so for instance a package could have
really strong tests but maybe not as
much Community Support or vice versa so
this things can kind of counter each
other right
so if we're flexible and adaptable in
our approach then we can more
effectively collect that body of
evidence
that's going to inform our sense of
trust in this wonderfully imperfect open
source world
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]